hello grammarians I'd like to bring up
the idea of the difference between a
common and a proper noun so the
difference between a common and a proper
noun is simply the difference between
something with a name and a more generic
version of that thing I'll give you a
couple of examples right off the bat so
speaking generally I am from a city the
specific city that I'm from is Chicago I
could talk about a frog generally but if
I were speaking of a specific frog I
would say Kermit the difference between
a common and a proper noun is merely the
difference between a general thing so
the side is more general and a specific
thing it's a it's a continuum so if you
are speaking of let's see a river any
old river that's a common noun but if
you're talking about a specific river
and it's a named River here that would
be the Nile say you could talk about a
mountain and that would be a common noun
because there are many mountains but if
you wanted to talk about a specific
mountain say Mount Kilimanjaro in
Tanzania you would put it you would
that's a proper noun so here are the the
properties of proper nouns proper nouns
are always capitalized and that means
that instead of using a little letter a
like that you would instead use a big
letter a like that common nouns are only
capitalized if you find them at the
beginning of sentences
so you might say mountains are my
favorite but you would also say
Kilimanjaro is my favorite mountain and
that is a lowercase non capitalized M as
opposed to this one which is uppercase
so that's the difference between common
and proper nouns if you're talking about
something general it's a common noun if
you're talking about something specific
it's a proper noun and the difference
between them is that you capitalize a
proper noun you can learn anything Dave
it out